momento de hablar de economía en france
24 y por ello le doy la bienvenida a mi
compañero jorge hurtado jorge los
republicanos hicieron una propuesta para
evitar el default de eeuu el 18 de
octubre cuenteros así es bueno el líder
republicano del senado mitch mcconnell
ofreció a los demócratas un acuerdo para
elevar el techo de la deuda de eeuu
hasta diciembre aunque esto aliviaría el
riesgo de incumplimiento de forma
temporal mcconnell exige que los
demócratas aumenten el límite de la
deuda mediante un proceso conocido como
reconciliación
actualmente andrés para aprobar la
medida es necesario que los 50
demócratas del senado voten a favor y
que al menos 10 republicanos lo hagan
algo inviable en la última votación es
el método propuesto por los republicanos
es la reconciliación que permite
aumentar o suspender el techo de la
deuda usando la mayoría simple de los
demócratas en el senado otorgada por el
voto de desempate de la vicepresidenta
kamala harris
hay menos de dos semanas para ponerse de
acuerdo al respecto si no se sube el
techo de la deuda sería la primera vez
en la historia que ese país caería en
una sensación de pagos
'jorge al fondo monetario internacional-
dio sus productos pronósticos de la
inflación global así es bueno el fm y
afirma que la inflación se va a mantener
los próximos meses en el mundo y antes
de volver a los niveles previos a la
pandemia hasta mediados del 2022 según
el organismo la inflación en las
economías avanzadas cerrará este año con
una media del 36 por ciento pero luego
se va a reducir de manera progresiva
hasta el 2% a mediados del 2022 para las
economías emergentes el repunte de
precios será más agudo con una inflación
del 6 8% a finales de este año aunque se
espera se normaliza paulatinamente hasta
el 4% a mitad del próximo año
andrés los precios de los alimentos
aumentaron un 40% a nivel global durante
la pandemia según este reporte lo que
implica un enorme desafío para los
países de bajos ingresos porque pasamos
a hablar ahora del banco mundial que
brindó datos sobre la economía en áfrica
bueno según la previsión la economía de
áfrica subsahariana crecerá un 33 por
ciento este año y un 3 5% en 2022 éste
repuntó andrés es impulsado por el
aumento de los precios de las materias
primas el levantamiento de algunas
restricciones por hobby 19 y un repunte
del comercio mundial según el banco
mundial el crecimiento podría llegar a
ser más alto del 5,1 por ciento en 2022
y del 5,4 por ciento un año después
dependiendo de la rapidez con la que se
implementen las vacunas aunque si la
tasa de inoculación es más lenta
reduciría las proyecciones de
crecimiento económico en ese continente
el grupo de negociadores sobre el cambio
climático asegura que el financiamiento
para ayudar a los países en desarrollo
para lidiar con el cambio climático
debería multiplicarse por 10 y alcanzar
la cifra de 1300 millones de dólares por
año para 2030 porque la producción de
automóviles no vive su mejor momento
porque definitivamente y bueno la baja
producción es a nivel global pero vamos
a enfocarnos en dos economías
principalmente brasil y méxico- que son
las más grandes de américa latina'
en estos países la producción se
desplomó en el comparativo anual de
septiembre de 2020 2021 arrastradas por
la escasez de chips de semiconductores
en toda la industria y los bloqueo
ferroviarios o en mexico en brasil por
ejemplo la producción bajó un 21 3% a
173 mil 287 unidades en septiembre con
respecto al mismo período del 2020
cuando esta industria estaba luchando
por reanudar la producción por la
pandemia en méxico la caída de la
producción fue del 33 punto 30 por
ciento y pasó a 208 mil 92 vehículos
mientras que las exportaciones de
automóviles también cayeron un 24 18 por
ciento y se ubicaron en 195 mil 294
unidades según los datos oficiales vamos
a conocer ahora los indicadores bueno
wall street cerró en terreno positivo
tras operar a la baja por el problema
del techo de la deuda en eeuu en europa
la bolsa cerraron a la baja también en
parís las pérdidas se recortaron después
de unas declaraciones del presidente
ruso sobre las exportaciones de gas de
su país hacia europa y en américa latina
las bolsas cayeron menos la de sao paulo
con cautela de los inversores por la
preocupación de la inflación y cuál es
nuestra cifra del día pero la cifra del
día es 3600 millones de dólares fueron
los ingresos del ego en el primer
semestre del 2021 esto es un 46% más que
en 2020 y se debe a la reapertura de sus
tiendas tras el cierre provocado por el
brote de kobe 19 recortado con la
información económica muchas gracias por
acompañarnos y ustedes también muchas
gracias por sintonizarnos quédense con
nosotros
[Música]